netflix's shadow and bone based off the
popular novels by leigh bardugo follows
the adventures of milo
an adorable baby goat oop sorry i was
reading my fan fiction script
developed by eric heiser this same guy
who brought us a rival and bird box
shadow and bone is an epic fantasy tale
spanning the 19th century
russian-inspired land of
ravka this video will be taking a huge
deep dive into the world
lore and answering some of the show's
biggest unanswered questions
also note that i won't be getting into
any of the big book spoilers so you
won't need to worry about that so
venture with me into the fold and make
sure to like and subscribe so that i can
one day have enough kruega to own my own
baby goat
the final episode begins within the fold
a shadow-like presence which has cut the
kingdom of ravka in half
to the north is the kingdom of fierda
who are at odds with rafka unlike the
ravkins fierda hunt the grisha believing
their powers to be dangerous
they even have an elite force of grisha
hunters called the druskela
who we see try to kill elena in episode
2.
whereas ravka is based off russia the
fjerdins are based off of scandinavia to
the south of ravka is shuhan we don't
see any of it this season but we do know
that elena the show's protagonist is
half
shoe and the ravkins have disdain for
the shuhan people
what's a shoe girl doing here back of
the line your friends
too what shuhan is based off mongolia
and china with it named after one of
china's three ancient kingdoms
the shuhan people are known for their
inhumane treatment of the grisha
even performing experiments on them in
order to gain advances in science
this makes them a technological rival to
rafka within the fold is a land called
the unsee which is inhabited by
creatures known as volcra
the word val comes from the french to
fly in episode 7 we learn how the fold
was created
centuries ago alexander kirigin also
known as the black heretic was wanted by
king anastas the king feared that
alexander had grown too
powerful even though alexander had
helped him win several wars
alexander is betrayed by his king and
his partner luda who he
loved dearly is killed when they attempt
to capture him
fearing his kind will be on the hunt
forever alexander takes the drastic step
of studying morozova's journals
ilya morozova also known as the
bonesmith was obsessed with creating
amplifiers
objects that increase egresia's powers
it's rumored that he created three such
amplifiers the stag the sea whip and the
firebird but we only see the stag this
season
morozova also dabbled in merzost a word
which is a combination of both
abomination and magic to understand this
we need to know how magic
operates in the grecia verse first that
grisha believe in something called
small science this is the belief that
all matter in the world can be broken
down to the same
essential parts if you have the ability
to manipulate this matter
you're considered agresha notice how
they don't call it magic rather small
science this is because the matter
doesn't come from nothing
we do not conjure from nothing we
manipulate that which already exists
around us
for example infernai don't conjure fire
out of nowhere they rather
summon combustible elements which are
already in the air
murzost on the other hand is the power
of creation of
life over death to use it one must
sacrifice something essential and this
usually drains the vitality of its
conjurer this is why we see that dark
veins appear around alexander the day he
creates the fold
as bagra alexander's mother warns him
the use of merzos can have unexpected
and deadly consequences and that's
exactly what happens when the king's men
track alexander down
whereas most grecia have to touch their
hands together to perform their small
science
merzos does not require it allowing
alexander to perform a spell so
powerful it creates the fold and turns
anyone within it
into a vulkra because alexander is an
eternal he spends the next centuries
basically in hiding
taking upon a new title alexander
kirigin and befriending a new king and
swaying him to see how the grecia can
help him win wars
alexander heads up the second army which
is composed of grecia
and trains them at a place called the
little palace located in the rafkin
capital of os alta
the grisha are split up into two orders
the first is called and please forgive
my pronunciation
the ethereal key which compose summoners
who can manipulate the natural elements
infernai fire tidemaker's water and
squalor's wind the sun and shadow
summoners like alina and alexander
technically fall under this category
ethrilky wear blue keftas as opposed to
the red keftas of the other order
the corporal ki the kefta is the
official uniform grecia's wear as part
of the second army the corporal ki or
corporal
kai are also known as the order of the
living and the dead and their powers
focus on the human body grisha in this
order consist of heart renders healers
and
tailors the show also introduces some
other grecia powers like a david who is
a duras the ability to manipulate
certain metals
and material nicks who we can see open
locks in episode 5.
alexander is basically biding his time
until the arrival of the sun summoner
someone whose power can help him
weaponize the fold and help him achieve
his real goal of taking control
of all of ravka for years alexander told
everyone including alina that he was the
descendant of the black heretic and that
he wants to undo the wrongs of his
ancestor by destroying the fold
i have devoted my life to undoing the
great sin of my forbearer
this is how he gets alina on his side
little does she know that alexander has
been the black heretic
all along but things change for alina
and alexander we previously saw them get
romantically involved when alexander's
mother bagra finds out the existence of
morizova's stag
a creature which could amplify alexander
so immensely no one could challenge him
she tells alina of alexander's true past
she must find that stag before he does
or it could have devastating
consequences for
all of ravka and this leads us to the
final episode of the season
alina has been bound to alexander after
a ceremony which fused parts of the stag
bones into each of them
one a bone collar on alina and two
another bone in
alexander's hand something alina will
later cut out of him allowing her
mal zoya and the crows to escape they
are on their way to east ravka to meet
with zlatan a general who has plans to
make east rafka its own independent
state by seceding zlatan does not want
the fold to be destroyed because the
fold is the only thing keeping the
king's armies from marching over and
stopping any sort of rebellion
zlatan has planned this is why he tasked
the conductor with assassinating elena
in episode 5.
if the sun summoner is killed then the
fold cannot be destroyed but alexander
has different plans
on board are several diplomats from the
other parts of the world
unbeknownst to them he means to show
them how with alina's power and his
combined
he can move the fold to crush his
enemies now
no one dares to stand in opposition to
him and his power and this is exactly
what he does moving the fold over the
town of nova krabirsk
destroying it and those within it this
is partly why zoya nazielensky turns on
alexander
some of her family lives there and are
likely dead because of him
it's also heavily implied that zoya and
alexander had a love affair before alina
arrived and took the spotlight so she's
probably bitter about that too
i shall relax when i have elena
deny meanwhile i have to bring up the
show's b
storyline involving the favorite titanic
there's enough room on the raft couple
nina and matthias nina was initially a
spy for alexander but went missing after
being captured by a group of druskela
she ends up on a ship where she meets
matthias who's been taught his whole
life that grisha are evil
and are out to kill his people this
dynamic is great as they learn to
overcome their biases and eventually
fall in love in one of the greatest
scenes of the series where nina
convinces him to get out of their wet
clothes and cuddle naked with him
damn you beguiling witch these two saved
each other even though their peoples
hate one another she saved him from the
ship wreckage and he her from falling
into an ice cavern but their love affair
is short-lived when they arrive in
arkhesk a town in northwest gravka
alexander's grecia led by fedor kaminsky
has tracked down nina and matthias
knowing that mathias will be killed by
the grecia she enlists the help of a
group of slave hunters by saying that
matthias is a slave hunter she's able to
cause a rift between the hunters and
grisha
allowing them to take mathias into their
custody but unfortunately for nina when
mathias wakes up he thinks she betrayed
him and that this was her plan all along
we'll get back to nina in a bit stowed
away aboard the skiff is mao alina's
lifelong friend who is discovered by the
crows who are composed of kaz
inej and jasper throughout the season
we've seen how this crew has tried to
kidnap alina so they can sell her to
make one million kruga this would allow
a nesh to be relieved of her indentured
servitude to a woman named helena
for jasper to be rich he's a big gambler
and for caz to reclaim his bar slash
in the crow club which he used as
collateral for taking inej on this
mission but things get a bit messy for
the team when they discover
alina is actually the sun summoner this
is a woman who could destroy the full
they end up fighting alongside her and
give
up their mission alina later hands kez a
piece of expensive jewelry which used to
belong to a queen of ravka in exchange
for not
telling anyone her whereabouts on board
the skiff we see how alexander's
advanced powers now that he is amplified
with elena
allow him to move the fold and destroy
nova kubisk
he talks about how today they will
redraw the maps which is ironic since
selena was a cartographer for the first
army
elena ends up stabbing alexander's bone
out of his hand and states
you cannot claim what was not given to
you the stag he claimed
did not choose him it chose alina
throughout the season alina has been
unsure of who she really is growing up
an orphan she suppressed her grecia
powers in order to stay with mal
her parents were killed by the fold and
when she's told she has these powers she
doesn't accept them
i don't want any of this why can't you
get rid of it
it's only when alina goes through this
journey she learns to accept who she is
and what she must do
jesper ends up taking on ivan the heart
render who he previously fought in
episode six
it's highly implied that jesper is a
grecia perhaps even with the ability to
guide his bullets
as ivan says what are you i really
should have shot you in the head
yeah mal ends up taking on alexander but
he's no match for this dark summoner but
as he says
i don't have to kill you darkling your
pastor did it for me
which is actually a callback to episode
7 when alexander said this to mal
i'm not going to kill you time
will do it for me alexander is
ironically swept up by the very creature
he ended up making when the fold was
created but as we'll soon see
we aren't done with alexander just yet
alina mal
kaz jesper enes and zoya emerge from the
fold where they discuss
what's to happen next here alina burns
her summoner robes no longer a part of
alexander's grisha
and also as a way to disguise herself
going forward
remember that no one in west ravka knows
what she looks like and with novacre
beerus destroyed she is presumed dead
alina promises that when she is stronger
she'll come back to tear down the fold
for good
you will tear it down just not today
currently the apparat is in control of
the kingdom having poisoned the king as
part of
alexander's plan the end of the season
ends with the team making their way to
ketterdam the capital of an island
kingdom called kirch ketterdam is where
the crows first started their adventure
in episode 1. and they have a lot of
enemies there including pekka rollins
and you may want to even count helena
there who has the deed to the crow club
kaz says he has a plan to get them out
of this mess but in order for it to work
they'll need a heart render
and just so happens to overhear them our
heart render nina
plan on them teaming up next season this
leaves us with mal and alina who are on
their way to recruit new allies in their
fight against the powers which control
ravka
and they're going to need all the help
they can get considering the final shot
of the season
is alexander emerging from the fold
alive
not only that but he is followed by
these shadow creatures
these are nichivoya not to be confused
with vulkra
first introduced in the second book a
siege and storm
they are said to be wrought from shadow
their faces devoid of features
they are almost like a velcro but their
shape is more human and they do not fear
the light
their backs do contain wings so it's
possible we could see them flying he'll
have these minions at his beck and call
and without having read the books my
guess is that he'll be looking to claim
the rapkin throne and track down alina
so the writers have done an excellent
job at creating a satisfying ending to
season 1
but also setting up events for season
two although a season two has not been
confirmed as of the time of this writing
it's very likely we'll be seeing more
shadow and bone considering it's been
the number one show on netflix for a few
days now
and that there is still plenty of
material from the books to cover but
what did you think of shadow and bone
i want to hear your thoughts and
theories in the comments below make sure
to like subscribe and share the video
and for more bad takes you can always
follow me on twitter and instagram
at think story yt until next time
remember
daddy loves you very much